it's about to be epic
it's about to be crazy
this is about to be epically crazy
in chronological order this is the
second Transformers movie it takes place
during the 90s shortly after Bumblebee
you find a kid struggling with how he's
able to provide for his family my
character Noah's ex-military and I feel
like I'm failing at every turn
then I meet Mirage
[Music]
[Applause]
Pete Davidson is the voice of Mirage
he's found like the rebellious Autobot
you're looking good man
there you go now we're friends
Elena works at the Museum she's
investigating something which brings
Noah into her life who are you uh
janitor really and that kind of opens a
whole new world for us
we're going this crazy Journey with the
Autobots we meet the maximals
we meet the next level of villains how
big can this guy be
uh he eats planets so like way bigger
than a planet
and there's a lot of Hearts they're
going against their biggest Nemesis
efforts
[Music]
they've never based anything like this
before